what are lower companions
lower companions is another term
uh from recovery As the adage goes
uh as you pursue your drinking or using
career uh it starts out fun drugs work
right it's a good time drinking is
pretty reliable it's going to produce a
certain kind of effect right and
alcoholics and drug addicts
um
they don't become addicts because it's
dysfunctional on day one they do it
because it's filling a need it is doing
something positive in their life in my
case it made me
feel like myself it was like wrapping
myself in a warm blanket where all my
insecurities and my fears would vanish
and I was able to be a social person in
Social settings which was something that
was very difficult for me my whole life
and
it functioned that way
for quite some time until it didn't and
then your life slowly starts to degrade
you start making decisions that you
rationalize that aren't in your best
interest it becomes a little lonelier
the chaos Factor starts to increase the
negative repercussions of your behavior
start to stack and escalate it starts to
get uncomfortable your higher companions
your good friends the people that love
you who have your best interest at heart
start to flee from the hills and you
begin to search out other people who are
vibrating at your wavelength who are not
going to give you a hard time for your
behavior and are more than happy to do
the thing that you want to do which is
to get loaded or get high
so you find yourself in really
compromising strange sometimes scary
situations with people you would not
ordinarily hang out with because you
share this one thing which is you just
want to lose yourself in this substance
or perhaps with people who are addicted
to
a certain Behavior it could be gambling
it could be you know it's like anything
you're going to find people who are
going to co-sign whatever Behavior it is
and then as the addiction escalates even
more you start to run through those
people
yeah you get lower and lower and lower
and lower until there's maybe that one
guy
and if not you're just home alone in a
dark room with the shades pulled down
um and that's how it ended for me for
sure the idea of lower companions
although not uh super romantic I think
is really useful and the first time I'd
ever heard of it was from you and I
think that
even for people that don't have a
substance addiction
dependency the idea of of people who
don't
have your best interests at heart
who don't make you show up as your
better self the self that you wish that
you were more of the time
I think there's something to take from
that and
you know I met across my nightclub
promoting career I met about a million
people face to face stood on the front
door of nightclubs three men a lot of
alcoholics and drug addicts correct yeah
and a lot of people that and in that
position 10 P.M to 1am outside of a
nightclub it's all the romance and none
of the destitution right because it's
full of energy they've got the girls on
their arm or the their girlfriends are
with them and you see them go in upright
and you see them come out horizontal
um who's the guy who comes out last
yeah it was that guy yeah well
yeah the idea of lower companions I just
think
there's a lot of people that listen to
the show and this is one of the things
like if you want to make me cry by
sending me a message this isn't a
request but the messages that I get that
make me weep or tear up the most are
ones where people say something like hey
man
like I'm a ice hockey player from rural
Canada
and
I'm 23 and none of my friends understand
me and when I listen to your show I feel
less alone
um I can't talk to any of my friends
about like what I'm interested in
all that they want to do is keep doing
the same thing every weekend the idea of
self-actualization is getting a bag in
with the boys on the weekend yeah right
and that is
you know
it's a even more in some ways maybe an
even more pernicious type of lower
companion because
does not there's not even the red flag
flying above their head do you know what
I mean yeah it's not necessarily a bad
influence it's just uh at best neutral
or perhaps somebody who's
um
insidiously but very gradually
undermining the quality of that contract
of water life
like you I also get a lot of those types
of messages and it's very meaningful to
me and I think what you're speaking
about is super important of course
there's that adage you're the average of
the five people oh yeah sorry the
average of the five podcasts probably
right
but I think it is Worthy
of examination this topic
because
most people
just
end up in the environment that they're
in and they never try to be in the in
the Pilot chair of how they're directing
their Community there's a lot of talk
about mentors I want this person to be
my mentor I want Tony Robbins to be my
mentor or garyvee or you know choose
your
choose your person but the truth is
each and every one of us in our
community is surrounded by people that
are wiser than us in various ways people
that can help us
and the nature of that Community can be
crafted and cultivated by you with a
little mindful intention people are good
they want to help people I know that I
feel good when I'm helping somebody that
is my primary purpose as a sober person
is to help other alcoholics to achieve
sobriety and that is the source of
um
my greatest sense of self when I'm in
that process so I think to the extent
that you can engage with the people
around you from a place of Greater
mindfulness and and exercise some
discretion about the people that you're
spending time with and not just go with
the flow because these are the dudes in
the locker room or what have you I think
you're you're getting yourself way ahead
of the game and listen not everybody has
a lot of high-minded people around them
and I think it's you know important to
you know note that and that's why shows
like yours and podcasts that are out
there I think are so important when I
was your age and when I was younger
I mean when I was a young man trying to
figure out my way in the world and who I
wanted to be there was no internet I
couldn't dial up a podcast and listen to
people tell stories about their careers
or or how they overcame hardship or how
they did what they did and and I'm a guy
who's embarrassingly well educated and
yet that was not available to me so when
I'm creating a show and I know you do
this as well I'm very conscious of that
person who lacks community in their
respective region
um and trying to make tools available to
that person that they ordinarily
wouldn't have access to and it's
incredibly powerful it's such a gift
there's an enormous library of people
sharing their stories about how they did
what they did or why they chose this
career and why it's important to them
and and how they think about their
relationships and and what it means to
you know be a man or be a woman and and
you know walk the planet with integrity
and those are the things that I'm always
thinking about in terms of the
conversation that I'm having like I want
to put out that high vibration but to
your point
choose your companions wisely and if
your friends are not raising the
vibration of what you're trying to
achieve or they're just giving you [__]
and making fun of you and whenever
you're Earnest and share a goal or a
dream they put you down it might be time
to upgrade and that's harsh uh
and there's gracious ways of doing that
but I think it's important to seek out
people who support you and find older
people who are a little bit further down
the path who can say here's how I did it
or I see where you're struggling
um plenty of those people are around and
it doesn't have to be one person I think
everybody should have a board of
advisors or a council of directors like
I don't call
um when I'm having a an issue
in my marriage uh I will call one person
but when I'm having a professional issue
or an issue around sobriety that's going
to be an entirely different person
everybody comes with their own unique
set of experiences and and wisdom and
you know accrued knowledge as a result
of how they live their life and these
are not famous people they're just
people in my community they're friends
that I've chosen
simply you know in many ways because of
the vibration that they carry and and
the way that they hold themselves out
into the world and I can tell you as
somebody who's been practicing that for
a very long time it's improved my life
in ways I couldn't possibly tabulate
like it is incredibly important who you
spend your time with I uh tweeted this a
little while ago saying I'm in the very
fortunate position where
most of my friends are also my role
models
and that's not that my role models are
my friends right it's the other way
around it's that the people that I have
I'm friends with
in the UK in America
people that are Beyond mundanely normal
do things that on a
dinnerly basis
I look at and I go that's extraordinary
like the way that they dealt with a
difficult conversation that they had to
have the way that they made a an awkward
decision with regards to their business
where somebody wasn't fitting and they
said it in the the right way early with
courage and bravery uh you know right up
to my housemate had his uh a clip from
his YouTube channel shared on Rogan a
couple of days ago so like he's fired up
for that I'm like you know each of these
different people like extraordinary in
some ways and unbelievably normal in
many many more ways
um and I understand you know if this is
if you're listening to this and it's
triggering a little bit of something
inside of you going well it must be nice
you know living in Austin Texas or
Calabasas or whatever and you're
surrounded by all these people and you
know you've got interest in blue ticks
knocking on your door asking to be
friends I got I I do get that but
the bottom line is that you will
devolve
to the lowest common denominator amongst
the friend group that you're in
and if you have the luxury of being able
to sit and listen to pontificating
podcasts for like two hours
you are probably built to take charge of
that situation and I would bet you that
there are
a really non-insignificant number of
people that live within three miles of
you who all would love to do the same
thing and yeah I
met about a million people across my
nightlife career and had a handful of
friends
um
that's because a lot of the guys that
worked with us came and went they moved
on to different careers Club promo isn't
a typically a long-term career
um
and I realized that my
funnel exposure to conversion friend
ratio was off
your funnel to conversion friend ratio
so think about how wide that's such like
a bro science term
welcome welcome to my podcast welcome to
my podcast Rachel
um the size of people that I was
reaching compared with the number of
friends that I had I understood was
so I couldn't believe it right and I was
like okay
something's up like this is the I
something is up and what it was
largely my fault and the reason that it
was my fault was that I was behaving in
a way
that I thought would make other people
like me
and what that meant was the people who
did like me
I didn't actually truly like
in large part
and the people who I would have liked
saw this person
that wasn't any yeah you become you're
unlikable to those people yes I'm
unlikable to the people that I would
like right for precisely the reason that
I'm playing this Persona right
um water rises to its own level
and you can't transmit something you
haven't got another recovery adage which
basically means it basically means if
you're trying to befriend somebody
because they have something that you
want
and you try to pretend that you're at
their level to say
whatever it is you think they want to
hear from you so that they
feel comfortable befriending you it's
very uh transparent that that is a false
and shallow gesture right like you can't
if you're sitting behind a microphone
and you're pontificating about a whole
bunch of [__] but it's not a result
of earned experience in your own life
then it's not going to have
the resonant effect that you think it
would have because
you didn't earn it right so
in recovery it means walking your talk
basically and when you walk your talk
and that talk and that walk is
integrated with a value system
that is slowly improving your life then
the water in your glass raises and the
level of your companions will raise in
lockstep with that so I think it's
important that if you want to attract a
certain caliber of person into your life
then you have to live your life in
accordance with the kinds of values that
would be attractive to that person and
as somebody who's spoken a lot about
dating like this is the same thing with
relationships right you're not going to
attract that mate
who is living a more aspirational life
than you until you can level up your own
life in other news this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mixed with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't it's a healthy
alternative to sugary electrolyte drinks
it's got a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
you might ask what do I want with an
electrolyte drink well it'll regulate
your appetite it'll curb Cravings it'll
help improve your brain function best of
all it tastes phenomenal first thing in
the morning this orange element salt in
water is outstanding your adenosine
system that caffeine acts on isn't even
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day so it's pointless having a morning
coffee your adrenal system which is what
salt acts on is active so this will make
you feel more alert more awake and
improve your hydration best of all
they've got a no BS no questions asked
refund policy so you can buy it and if
you do not like it for any reason they
will give you your money back that's how
confident they are that you'll love it
head to drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom to get a free sample pack
of all eight flavors with your first box
that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Rich then press here for the full
episode in all its Glory